it's always fun to go back in time power
of the Daleks now this will be the first
of what will hopefully become a semi
regular fixture on this channel which is
my reviewing classic era Doctor Who
stories now I have seen a few in my time
I've still got a lot of others to get
through it and as I see them I do plan
to do reviews on them but I need to do
something a little bit especially
because power of the Daleks premiered
very recently now this is an older story
in fact the very first second doctor
story but it has been lost I mean the
video footage does not exist anymore but
all the audio survived so between that
some still images and script notes and
what they know the thing was supposed to
look like BBC has put together an
animated version using all the original
audio and that was presented ahead of
this past Christmases Doctor Who
Christmas specials so power the Daleks
what do I think it's pretty good
I mean it's dated in a way that a lot of
older doctor who is IIe you've got
things like you we only have maybe a
dozen characters but they try and tell
you there's this whole colony of people
so you kind of feel the constraints of
the budget is one of the six part
stories so you can clip that they
stretched it a little thinner than it
probably should have been I think a four
part sure would be fine and in what
feels a little bit like a holdover from
the tail end of the first doctors tenure
the doctor himself kind of gets taken
out of commission a little bit he gets
jaded at one point there were lengthy
stretches where we don't get a whole ton
of him and I think part of that is also
due to the fact that they kind of over
complicated the story going on I in the
location where he and his companions
have ended up and then trying to explain
all that and untangle the web of
motivations of everybody who's already
there kind of just necessitates
sidelining the doctor a little but as
far as what the plot is this is as I
said the first story following the
regeneration of the first doctor into
the second and he and his two companions
Ben and Polly who are companions I'm not
particularly familiar with but they land
on this planet Vulcan in a
they never specified a time period but
it presumes some sort of future you know
relative to where we are and Vulcan is a
colony with some sort of twisty internal
politics going on and in the middle of
this a scientist has discovered a
capsule and inside are three Daleks that
appear to be dead but you know dialects
and so scientists fascinated by this
discovery is trying to get them
reactivated while the doctor is
desperately trying to get anyone around
so listen to him do explain that these
things must be destroyed now one of the
first things that I caught that was
really interesting was realizing how
much has been intentionally borrowed
from well this episode and classic
Doctor Who in general in new Doctor Who
I mean very specifically the dog that's
going I am your servant which got reused
in victory of the Daleks so I
immediately recognized that and made me
appreciate victory of the Daleks a
little bit more that they brought that
back and recycled it caches sometimes
when they do that like the whole Daleks
are the masters of Earth was it who that
was used in the stolen earth that was a
callback to some classic Doctor Who so I
like when I learn more stuff that and
that has been repurposed in and been
called back to in the new series and
that's always fun for me to discover it
was really interesting to see how kind
of fully formed the notion of
regeneration seemed to be right out of
the gate and by that I just find it
really interesting that they seem to
know well I'll have to be very vague and
loose about it in terms of explaining
exactly what happened in exactly why and
how the doctor is different we can very
clearly see but at points the doctor
refers to meet past doctors the doctor
doesn't even really refer to himself at
all you're like what is going on and
he's figuring out you know his new south
and he gets hold of the little pipe his
ridiculous hat at one point but he's off
by just a little bit
he knows he's off by a little bit and
just all the wonkiness that we have come
to expect from regeneration it's just
fascinating for me to find out now by
getting to see the fact that was all
there right from the beginning there's
stuff that I don't know if I had
actually intellectually thought about it
but it was
assumed must have been added in later
and refined as the show went on but to
realize how much stuff this series
nailed right out of the gate back in the
60s it's it's just wonderful as I said
though the story is kind of a product of
its time it but if you like classic era
Doctor Who you'll probably find
something to enjoy in this it's hard to
recommend as as any kind of early look
into classic Doctor Who for people who
are more up-to-date on new who but
haven't gotten back into the classic era
so far and part of the reason for that
is I think doing it animated hurts it a
little bit now having said that I'm
don't I don't regret that they did an
animator and I would much rather see it
animated in this fashion than not see it
at all but it's very very limited
animation it's very obvious that they
didn't spend a whole ton of money on
this animation and you get used to it in
terms of you know if you watch any sort
of chunky animation for life you just
kind of get you suing you roll with it
but where it falls down is that there
are there will be shots and there will
be moments that the nothing really
happens and you know that in the
live-action you would have that would
have been the actors chance to do
something you know with their face and
your really get a read on you know
what's going on you know what are they
thinking hmm but with these really rigid
barely moving facial expressions that
are really kind of locked in they just
kind of they haven't looked back and
forth and that's about it and you really
you feel those pauses a lot more than
you're supposed to because obviously
with real actors they would have been
able to communicate more in their
physical performance that you know they
didn't they didn't have the budget to
him to do that level of animation and
that level of nuance and so that that
kind of hurts a little bit versus if we
actually still had the real footage
again though if you are sort of used to
the pacing of classic Doctor Who and if
you enjoy that at all definitely check
this out if you missed it so those are
my thoughts on power of the Daleks did
you see it what did you think about it
whatever you thought drop something down
in the comments and let's talk about it
don't forget to like subscribe hit that
little
down there so you get notifications when
new stuff goes up follow me on Twitter
at Council of geeks check out the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher I put links down the
scriptures for those and until next time
this council is adjourned